all right amato
where'd you grow up where are you from
where is i i'm from the macarthur park
area
so l.a basically yeah yeah like a sixth
and alvarado
yeah not far from here and uh you had
your both your parents growing up
uh no my father he went to prison when i
was three
and uh my mother raised me and my
brothers you know
so dad that was in prison for most your
childhood yeah until he died
oh really what was he in for he was
there for uh
uh murder you know he killed somebody
yeah was he in gangs yeah he was a gay
member yeah and then my brothers
were gay members and you avoided it
somehow yes i did
because of that you know since i was so
much younger i was able to see it
from a different perspective and saw
that it was in was it the life of me you
know yeah
and where did your life go from from
there after you left home
um i went to prison too i used to be a
lifer
you know where were we in prison for i
killed somebody when i was 18.
and uh he was a guy that was trying to
kill me and my friend he ended up
killing my friend
you know i mean and uh in the process of
defending myself i end up killing him
um i later on got it overturned and i
got out but i did 11 years
you know almost 12 years on that but it
was self-defense it wasn't self-defense
yeah he got me for a manslaughter
you know see what they got before you
know there is no self defense in
california
you know no such thing well that's what
they tell you
you know there's no you can't take the
law into your own hands you know you
have to
you know find a police officer or
something to help you
but i was scared you know i mean i
thought he was gonna kill me for sure
and i just was trying to fight the best
i could and i ended up
you know overcoming him but it was the
way that it happened that
that got me in trouble after it happened
uh
i was afraid and uh they had to catch me
so since i ran
it made me look like like i was doing
something underhanded but i was just
scared you know i was young i was scared
i didn't want to do the rest of my life
how did you tell him i killed him with
an axe you know
but uh he's building older buildings
there's a lot of uh
those fire axes and um
i mean the idea when i was he was
chasing me through the building
that was like my only hope i have to
defend myself and uh
i picked the axe out of the case and uh
it's how i killed him it was kind of
gruesome
you know so so from 18
till like
yeah yeah actually 31.
the time i got for a couple years yeah
yeah
that's when i got out you know 31. oh
you got
when you were 31. yeah i'm 43 now oh you
were 43. yeah
so and uh so today you're you're
living where you're on skid row i'm on
skate roll uh
i just got back from uh mexico uh i have
a mother who's
ill and i want to go take care of but
she lost her battle with cancer and uh
i came back i buried her and came back
after uh i culminated a relationship
that i had out there i ended up getting
in a relationship the time i was taking
care of her
but it didn't didn't work out for us so
i decided to come back
and uh i've been back for about a year
and a half
you know now about uh about a year into
coming back i started dating somebody
and uh just changed my life you know
i had a lot of plans before you know i
had a i know i was excited about being
back you know and doing things
you know uh again but i mean
contracting hiv changes everything you
know or at least like what i thought i
knew about it i'm starting to learn a
lot more about it now that i have it i'm
starting to look into it
and when i was growing up i mean it was
a death sentence you know if they told
you you had hiv you were gonna die
and i mean when i found out i was like
what am i gonna do
go to school you know get a job and
what's the point
so i started getting high you know and
i've never been one to get high
you know but it just seemed like that
was the right thing to do at the time
now i'm transitioning even out of that
and then i'm like thinking myself what
are you doing
like you know this is stupid you know
you have a limited amount of time
you know do something with yourself you
know being high is not going to be
is that going to enable me to do that
i'm not concentrating really i mean this
is going to be the fire of my life
you know i mean and uh from when i
understand how i can live a normal life
if i take care of myself you know and i
stop killing myself with drugs and just
this lifestyle
so i'm trying to get out of here you
know i was trying to take me and my
girlfriend out but
she's she's not she's stuck here you
know
this is her life you know she loves this
he loves
something about this place you know yeah
i just i
i don't feel i can save her you know
so i have to save myself i struggle with
that in the beginning because
i felt bad leaving her behind you know i
don't leave people behind to die you
know
but i mean i have to do something
otherwise i'm gonna die with her and i
can't die out here
you know i have to do something
how did you contract aids in the first
place
um i was sleeping with her i'm thinking
i mean i don't know how you find out
like where you get it from
but i've never been one sleep around i
didn't want to sleep i made it at a
point i'd never sleep with girls out
here
and this girl approached me you know and
asked me told me she liked me
and uh like my style and you know wanted
to have me as a boyfriend
what do i think and i thought to myself
you know who am i to deny i would you
know deny her
you know i know what she she did and
stuff like that
but she seemed like a nice girl you know
it was just you know
maybe needed a better example
so i said okay well you know let's see
where this goes
uh about a year into our relationship i
started seeing how she lived
and uh how promiscuous she was and how
she was doing it behind my back and i
started finding out the guys she was
sleeping with
some of these guys had hiv you know so i
encouraged her to go get tested
and she did and it turns out she did
have
not only hiv a bunch of other stuff you
know and um
everything when they go get tested
confirmed i didn't even go get tested
for like six months
you know because it shocked me when i
found out she had it
but not like when i found out i really
truly had it you know
and i don't know how to describe what
it's like you know it just knocks your
hair out
you know it's even embarrassing to tell
friends and family like
like you know you want to tell them to
help you and you want to explain to them
what's happening in your life but it's
hard to tell them you have hiv
you know like it makes you feel like
dirty you know like i don't know it's
just hard
it's hard to tell them you know you know
and so it's hard to reach out and ask
for help but i recently done that you
know
and it took a lot of courage to tell
them i had hiv
because i know they're to tell other
people and i'm always going to be that
guy
you know who had aids you know
i never i never thought that i would be
that guy you know
but let's see we'll see how it goes you
know
yeah it's hard the medications they have
now are
they're great yeah they can really save
your life man
i mean i mean now the way that i'm
barely starting to find out stuff
because like i said i went
i'm barely starting to get into like the
treatment and everything like that so i
don't know too much about it
but i mean there's pills that i mean
we're basically cleaning out my blood
and my system so well that
if you test me i won't even come out you
know i mean and i want to be able to get
my partners infected so that means i
could maybe start dating
you know and i could maybe have a
regular life like uh like maybe having a
wife i've never been married i don't
have kids
maybe i can still do that you know and i
thought that was
not a possibility for me anymore and
that was always been my dream you know
to have a family
you know and uh you know it seems to me
from what they're telling me it looks
like i could still have a normal life
if i start making the changes now you
know and i
you know do what i have to do to get
better
you know if not it's going to kill me
you know i see people out here
you know how fast they deteriorate and
it takes them you know
i don't want to be taken that way like i
took my girl's mother
you know she looked healthy she looked
fine and one day she just died
and it's crazy you know i don't want
that to be me so many people are dying
out here right now
it's crazy how many people are dying you
know from all kinds of different stuff
you know
and tomorrow it could be me you know
they could be like oh remember that guy
yeah oh he was a nice guy oh yeah well
he died you know what happened he had
hiv
or you know he did die from an overdose
or whatever it is you know
i don't want that to be me you know i
want to
i want to do better than this maybe come
back and help and inspire others to do
the same thing
show them that it can be done you know
because there's not a lot of people
doing that
no one ever comes back and tells you
their success story you know i don't
ever hear anything like that
you know no one ever comes back and
tells me hey man it's possible you know
like you know this is what you can do
you know i think if someone came back
and did that
that would help a lot of people you know
this is it's not over you know
you know it's uh this is only the
beginning you know
and that's the way i feel now you know
it's like now i have something to fight
for you know
i have something to live for and i died
for you know
but your attitude is great considering
the tragedies you had to go through
yeah i don't have a lot of family like i
said i just lost my mother
she was like the last real family i had
so i like i'm alone
you know but you know
i don't need i mean that's all i need i
guess you know
i know that if she found out i had hiv i
mean it would have broke her heart
you know i'm glad that she passed away
and didn't have to find out
you know because it would have broke her
heart you know
to find out her youngest son you know
that of aids
you know cause she probably thought
about aids the away i used to think of
aids yeah it's changed a lot
yeah it's not like it used to be you
know
i mean they talk there's um commercials
and all kinds of stuff now it's that
they used to make you feel like it was
dirty before like it was like you know
only bad people got that you know
but i noticed now that you know what
anybody can catch it you know i mean
it's it's everywhere
if you're not careful you can get it you
know and you have to really be careful i
was not
careful enough you know i took it for
granted and
i had unprotected sex you know you don't
really think about it empathy says oh it
only takes one time
you don't think about that i never
really did not took it that seriously
once i got to know a girl
for a while and i knew her well enough
yeah you could have under protective sex
with her you know
but that could have been it right there
you know or i could maybe infect other
people
if i was careless like that you know and
mess up their lives
it just changes lots of things for me
you know
it makes me a lot more uh conscious you
know it makes me a better person
in a way it's good that i cut hiv you
know because
i was not really living you know like
i'm like i intend to live now you know
you know i still got to find out how bad
i am
you know or like what kind of move what
a strain i have and
those are all things that i'm waiting
for right now and i'm a little worried
about it because there's
stuff there is stuff that can you know
there's parts of aids that
is pretty strong and it can't kill me
and maybe i won't have all the
opportunities that i'm talking about but
i feel hopeful you know
you know i feel strong you look great
you know you never know you're sick with
anything yeah you know i don't feel
i don't feel sick at all you know so i
don't i feel
optimistic you know i feel a little bad
about my girlfriend
because she just had a messed up life
you know i feel bad for her she didn't
have like uh the examples that i had in
life i had a great mother
you know i had good people in my life
that taught me the right things you know
that enabled me to
have the perspective that i have about
things you know even though i grew up in
a real bad neighborhood
and i grew up you know i spent most of
most of my life in prison
you know i just always had good examples
i've always been blessed you know to be
surrounded by good people
you know
all right thank you so much for talking
to me and sharing your story my pleasure
i hope it helps somebody you know
i think it will thank you
you